We can also encode data into our
visualization using color. We can typically include
values with color in 2 different ways,
hue and saturation. They can be used individually
or in combination. Color hue is what we typically refer to as color like red
or green or blue. Different colors used
together usually in the key categorical data where
each color represents different group. So if we're
using our baseball data maybe green is short
stops, red is outfielders and orange is second
basemen, something like that. Saturation is the intensity of
color for a given hue. So if you select a color as blue, high saturation will be
very blue and the color would look faded
as you decrease your saturation. We usually use saturation
to encode intensity or quantity of a value. So
maybe if we were encoding the number of home runs
with saturation, more home runs would be darker and fewer
home runs would lighter. Or, if we were encoding Aadhaar
enrollments, more enrollments would be darker and fewer enrollments
would be lighter. We could also use hue and saturation
in combination. So you can see here that no hue
and no saturation is set to 0 and in this
particular encoding, the more saturated our purple-like color is,
the more negative we are. And the more saturated
our green-like color is, the more positive we are.
This might accentuate the differences in value and tell
us when the value is positive or negative and
how intense the absolute value of that effect is.
When using color to encode information, a pretty good
general rule of thumb is that you shouldn't use more
than a dozen colors to encode categories effectively. If
you were to use more than 12 colors, it might
be hard to quickly differentiate between categories, and your visualization
is going to become a little bit harder to parse.